ghost stories is a British horror movie
written and directed by Andy Nieman and
Jeremy Dyson the film follows a
paranormal investigator as he attempts
to debunk three chilling ghost stories
the three stories themselves revolve
around a night watchman working in an
old factory a teenager whose car breaks
down and a businessman who is awaiting
the birth of his child as the film
progresses we learn that everything is
not as clear as it seems and I will be
discussing the major plot twists and
narrative choices that the film takes
with that out the way I'm definition and
this is my ending explain video for
ghost stories we follow professor
Goodman a hard skeptic on his most
intriguing paranormal case after
receiving a note from a long thought
dead Pierre named Gorman the professor
tracks down his idol and finds the
recluse on death's door
gifted three unexplainable cases by the
mysterious figure Goodman Ponder's
whether to take them or not he notices
two boys playing on the beach with the
dead bird and sets off to interview the
first one of his three storytellers he
comes into contact with Tony a night
watchman whose daughter suffers from
locked-in syndrome this is a paralyzing
disease that leaves the victim bed bound
and unable to move but fully conscious
of their environment this plays heavily
into the main plot and Tony's story he
recounts how on his final night at work
he was haunted by a mysterious Specter
one that takes the form of a young girl
and a yellow dress and haunts him with
the corpse of a bird chase through the
disused building lights are disconnected
mops take on a life of their own shadows
leap out at him and doors unlock by
themselves eventually Tony is led into a
room filled with mannequins to me they
symbolize his daughter lifeless to look
at there is still something within when
attacked by a ghost that puts its finger
in his mouth Tony comes to the
terrifying realization that he has
abandoned his daughter and the next day
he goes to visit her once more in the
hospital this story guilt trips the
professor and her visiting his father
who too suffers from locked-in syndrome
but there is little he can do
rapped with the guilt of abandoning him
he journeys out to see the second of his
cases Simon this mysterious boy is
strange photographs on the wall the boys
playing in a dark tunnel parents with
their back turned and a strange boy
running around upstairs the house as a
whole will send shivers up the spine of
anyone who watches it and it is the
perfect setting for the character
Simon's story centers around him driving
home and hitting a satyr is half man
half goals monster chases him into the
woods where he is attacked by a tree
since his attack Simon has barricaded
himself into his home afraid to answer
the door and this once again plays into
the locked-in motif that would come at
the film's conclusion the professor
leaves but when driving home he
hallucinates and sees himself trapped in
his car dying Mike is the final story
this rich country man talks about the
night his wife gave birth to their son
and how even though he was what many
would consider deformed he still loved
him even if no one else did this story
is littered with symbols such as a girl
in a yellow dress and many locks and
keys during its selling Goodman notices
a strange boy in a parka coat following
him and when might commit suicide at the
story's climax it's clear that things
aren't as they seem
the professor races back to Gorman who
reveals himself to be Mike in disguise
tearing through the scenery he
transports the professor to his
childhood where the true meaning behind
each tale is revealed as a child the
professor witness to bullies force a
mentally disabled child named Kojak into
a tunnel where he had an asthma attack
and died Goodman had the opportunity to
save the boy but instead did nothing and
this guilt has weighed heavily over him
these two bullies are the boys that
Goodman witnessed after visiting Gorman
and saw in photographs at Simon's house
clearly the moment weighs heavily over
everything he does in his lately as the
character wracked with disappointment of
his deed attempted to commit suicide by
locking himself in his car and pumping
the inside full of carbon dioxide
failing this he is left with severe
brain damage the professor is now in
fact in a coma hallucinating the stories
that horned him we see the three
characters enter the room in what is a
very Wizard of Oz moment and discuss his
situation locked in his own mind
professor Goodman is an
able to do anything and his surroundings
are inspiring his imagination we see a
doll in a yellow dress at his side Tony
uses a mock to clean the floor a bird
hits the window the hospital equipment
that Gorman had surrounds his bed mike
shines lights in his eyes and a
finger-like tube hangs out of his mouth
similar to Tony's daughter Simon and
Mike he is locked in his own mind unable
to change the horrible mistake that he
made as a child
there are several interpretations to be
taken from ghost stories and the film
definitely climaxes in a way that means
there's no real clear-cut answer to
exactly what is real and what is in
Goodman's imagination
I love the repetition of locks and keys
and how many things from the past played
off in the final scene recently I read
the graphic novel Watchmen by Alan wah
Dave Gibbons and John Higgins and in
that there's a chapter called old ghosts
in which the characters have to deal
with their past coming back to haunt
them that graphic novel discusses how
ghosts are not ghosts but they are in
fact our memories coming back and
reminding us of horrible things that we
have done which is why they horrify is
so much
metaphorically professor Goodman has had
to deal with his own ghosts and the
skeletons in his closet have haunted him
until he viewed death is the only escape
failing in his final act he must now
live out the rest of his life trapped in
a bed where his own personal ghost
manifests every thought he has a
never-ending nightmare so what did you
think of ghost stories personally I
thought the film had some very tense
moments but failed to deliver as much as
I'd hoped
due to the terrible makeup I was able to
instantly spot that Martin Freeman was
playing Gorman and this took me out of
the tale quite a lot the ending was also
slightly jarring and due to this I was
unable to attach myself completely to it
however it is very well acted and the
night watchman's tale had me on the edge
of my seat so I definitely recommend
going to see it for that alone with
there being so much to take from the
film I'd love to hear your thoughts on
it there are several ways to interpret
the movie and hundreds upon hundreds of
Easter eggs dotted throughout their
payoff in the climax what was your
favorite moment comment below and let me
know
and if you like this video please check
out the recent ending explanation that I
did for a quiet place make sure you
subscribe to my channel as I do videos
like this all of the time and you won't
want to miss the next horror film I
analyze thanks very much
take care peace
[Music]